it's time for the us open tennis
championships and we're going to be
looking at how ibm is helping craft the
digital fan experience predict the
winners and provide the cloud support
all served up on this episode of ibm
tech now i promise that's my only tennis
punt
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
ibm has been the official technology
partner of the u.s open tennis
championships for more than 30 years
and the relationship goes much deeper
than just slapping a logo on the court
year after year ibm ix which is the
experience design part of ibm consulting
works with the usta to integrate
technology from dozens of partners
automate key business processes and use
the power of ai to transform data into
key insights
to do this ibm ix uses collaborative
design thinking brought to life by the
ibm garage methodology an end-to-end
model for accelerating digital
transformation
this generally involves three stages the
co-create stage where squads agree on
the nature of the challenges prioritize
them and conceptualize solutions the
co-execute stage where development teams
build minimum viable products or
solutions and test them and the
cooperate stage which involves ongoing
performance management improvement and
product development
the usta and ibm consulting cooperate
all year round to develop and refine the
digital experience for you the fan at
home
to learn more about the creation of the
digital fan experience check out the
blog post i've got linked in the
description of this video
now one of the coolest aspects of the us
open experience is how ibm consulting
helps turn tennis data into engaging fan
insights through ai and automation
using structured and unstructured data
the ibm power index with watson ranks
player momentum and combines performance
and punditry
from these analyses a series of
predictive insights are generated
including ones to watch which are
players who may outperform their tour
rank
upset alerts which predict when a lower
seated player might win and likelihood
to win which provides a win probability
model for each player
ai and automation are also used to
generate something called match insights
which provides head-to-head pre-game
analysis of every match
match insights uses natural language
generation to translate stats into
easily read sentences on a fact sheet
it's pretty amazing to see such a
massive amount of data transform quickly
into useful predictions and metrics
about the players and matches
to learn more about the process hit the
link below
underpinning all of this is the cloud
platform and the usta relies on ibm
hybrid cloud technology to accommodate
the volume variety complexity and
mission critical nature of the data
the us open uses a combination of
on-premises private and public clouds to
develop containerized kubernetes
applications on red hat openshift
this allows the team to write code once
and then run it on any cloud rapidly
escalating the rate of innovation for
the ibm consulting team
it also allows development teams to work
remotely and streamlines the creation
and delivery of new fan experiences
the open nature of this environment even
enables the usta to seamlessly integrate
functionality from third party providers
such as us open fantasy tennis
to dive deeper into how hybrid cloud
technology supports innovation and
growth at the us open hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now